that's more breaking news for this
morning we're just hearing the de search
is underway from three year old British
girl who's gone missing in the Algarve
area of Portugal and she went missing
last night hundreds of people have been
searching for the girl and that search
continuing this morning so we were
trying to get as much on that as fought
for you as soon as we can
that a missing girl in lutz and we will
bring it to you as soon as we get
further detail let's just bring you some
more detail on the breaking news that we
brought you a short while ago
three-year-old british girl has gone
missing while on a family holiday in
Portugal it's been confirmed by the
Foreign Office it's more detail on this
for you now the Portuguese police are
investigating the disappearance from a
holiday complex in prior deluxe in the
western Algarve I think we've got a map
we can show you there the Foreign Office
spokesman said that he understood the
girl's parents had gone to have dinner
once their children were asleep last
night but returned to check on them only
to find that the little girl had gone
missing and they reported the little
girl's disappearance straight away and
they are being given consular assistance
in Portugal but no word on to where this
little girl has gone and considerable
efforts being made indeed to try to
track down it extraordinary difficult
time for her parents but it would appear
that she went missing after the parents
had gone to have supper went back to
check that she was okay
check on the children were okay and the
three-year-old had gone missing as soon
as you have any further detail on that
we'll bring it to you
a three-year-old British girl has gone
missing in the Algarve in Portugal of
course we can speak now to dan.mason
who's a journalist who works in that
area dan thanks for joining us on Sky
News sunrise this morning what are the
details that you've gleaned so far well
a and all I basically know is that the
child is obviously a Mark Warner and
establishment and was reported missing
around p.m. last night she's three years
old answers to the name of Madeleine or
Maddy fair hair and the most of the
people who didn't read the area were
searching it's about four o'clock in the
morning yesterday's absolutive had jism
down the beach etc to no avail and I've
just been down
this morning to the club again to see if
there's any more news and the situation
is basically the same so anywhere I
don't know the family personally I was
just basically heard via word of mouth
of this happening